trying to make the best of the Wuhan
lockdown suit lee jung and his family
traveled to Wuhan
for the Lunar New Year even once the
coronavirus lockdown ends they will face
an additional 14 day quarantine when
they get back home to Shanghai like
millions of other Chinese across the
country the children might be smiling
but the adults are very concerned how
you feel what did what do you want to
tell people out there how you feel and
what it's like so I think they just the
first importance don't get this virus on
board
otherwise you can die if you go to
hospital possibilities no no bad no no
enough dr. King 2 2 2 treaty and that's
something he has had to speak with his
children about 8 to 13 Souls photos show
the empty streets of Wuhan but the
shelves in the supermarkets are not
supplies he said are being brought in by
the military like Wuhan the big concern
for the central government here in
Beijing is increasing the medical
capacity for the growing number of
infected in Hubei Province more beds for
the ill and more supplies for those
treating them large gymnasiums in an
Exhibition Center have been converted
into makeshift hospitals in Wuhan along
with the two new hospitals built for the
coronavirus completed this week there
are now more than 6500 new beds for
those infected but with the spread of
the virus these new beds barely cover
the increase of confirmed new cases in
Hebei province from just the last week
scott hilar al-jazeera Beijing